We're so excited.
Chris was kind enough to do transformations
on two of our VFFs, Jamie and Maria.
And I can't wait to see them
and we'll get to them in just one minute.
But I was wondering if I could pick your brain
for a minute, Chris?
Please do, Drew.
Well, when I would go to salons
and I would change my hair, which was every other day
because I tried every cut color and style,
I would always bring magazine references
because I was positive
that I was going to get something lost in translation.
I think a lot of the pictures people would probably bring in
are the people you have-
the very hairstylists and giant stores that you have done.
For example, the glass hair trend,
that's something that everybody's obsessed with.
And you really started that with Kim K
if I can call her that.
Yeah, Kim K, call her Kimmy.
We actually started that back in Paris a while ago
and it was just this very straight hair
and we tried to get it shiny or even shinier
and then it became a big thing.
I mean, yeah, you're right.
I guess, I think that the women I work with are,
I guess so known and I kind of like it that way
just because we have a great relationship.
They are amazing women
and we love to create different looks.
So the fact that these things
become then a trend and sort of take off.
It's always so exciting to see.
But you know what, you got it right, Drew.
If you're ever going to go to the salon and ask for a look
taking a picture is the perfect way to describe it
to your hairstylist because it just stops you
getting lost in translation.
Oh, and I've had those moments
which is why I bring those reference sets.
Yeah, it's a little scary.
Can I just say actually, Drew
you've been on a few of the mood boards
before with your back at the '90s
with the clips and you had some dues,
you've had some looks throughout the year and I love it.
Thank you.
I tend to think like hair first, as certainly as an actor,
I would find my way into a lot of characters
with the hair first.
I was like, what is that frame?
And it was just a really good entry point,
and I always love people like Barbara Streisand
and Jane Fonda and Madonna and Lady Gaga,
David Bowie, those sort of, and Kim K
calls you a transformationalist person
because it does change you,
it changes your attitude, your confidence level,
it gives you kind of a new attitude and character.
Hair is a big thing.
And it's an important thing.
Huge.
Yeah, absolutely.
What's a good product to get that trend of glass hair.
One of my favorite go-tos is the Dream Coat,
it's Color Wow's Dream Coat.
It's a transformative kind of, I guess prep to the hair.
As you put it on wet hair,
and it basically changes the whole texture
of hair once it's dried.
And it also has like a waterproof technology,
so it has a sealant against any water or humidity
cause everyone knows that's the worst thing
you do your hair and you go outside
and the weather changes it.
So that's one of my go-tos for blast out for sure.
But you know, just going back to what you were saying
directly about how you get ready for characters.
It's funny because I guess every time I work
with the clients that I worked with,
the first thing I always say is like,
"Okay, who do you want to be?"
For example, if it's J.Lo I'm like,
is it Jenny on the block?
Is she movie J.Lo, is she performance J.Lo?
Cause everything is like a different character
that you kind of stepping in.
So when everything tells a story,
which I think is I guess why I started doing hair.
I used to do my mom's hair when I was nine years old
because ironically, I used to try and make it look
like a Hollywood star because creatively I liked it.
But when I told her to stand up and look in the mirror,
I would see her shoulders go back
and she would forget for a minute
she was a mom of five and she would feel herself.
And I remember that feeling was so infectious for me
making people feel good about the way they look
and kind of give them them that alter ego, if you like.
I guess it's still why I do it.
It's still that kind of process
of just making people look and feel great.
Cause that's when the magic happens, right.
It does change the body language.
It changes the confidence and it changes the inner dialogue.
100%.
I don't know what to take it a step further.
I even saw it like go in a stage,
I actually started to work with cancer patients.
That's how I started to work with wigs,
now I work with wigs in celebrities.
But back then it was working with these women
that I knew that were really strong women.
And they were regular regular clients.
They had cancer, they lost their hair and they would come in
and they would have lost their identity.
And my job was to give them their identity back
and make them feel like they could somehow face the day,
and it was almost like emotional medicine
and there's so much behind it.
But honestly the main story
is that great hair really can make your day feel better
and just make you be able to go ahead with it
with more confidence.
Which is for me, why I do what I do, I love it.
Some of our VFFs wanted to come to you
and have you come to their rescue.
Shall we take a quick look at Jamie?
Let's roll the tape.
We had some fun, we had some fun with it.
Oh, I can't wait to see!
Hi, my name is Jamie as a busy mom of five
and a full-time nurse, especially during the pandemic
it's been super challenging to find time for myself.
One thing that I really, really need help with is my hair.
I'm totally clueless when it comes to blow drying my hair.
So my hair is super thin.
They know there has to be some products out there
or styling tips that can help me get some volume.
Maybe get some lift up here.
Drew and Chris, I really really need some help
in the hair department.
Can you help me?
Jamie, how you doing?
Good, how are you?
I'm so excited to do this with you.
So first of all what we're gonna do
is we're going to take the Color Wow
Raise the Root Volumizing Spray.
First you're going to spray this through the roots.
This all the roots get some look.
You should have a round brush.
You take that section, lift it right up in the air
and then just literally wrap it around.
What we're going to do now Jamie,
because the hair is not wet,
it's not going to take long to dry
and all we're going to do is dry the product in.
Then you should get that face frame
in kind of volume with the front.
But I just kind of put the Velcro roller in and let it sit.
If you leave him in five to 10 minutes, it's great.
Jamie, we're going to take this texturizing spray
and then just blast it through the roof.
Now this basically just gives your hair
a little bit more volume.
At this point, I just like to blast the hairdryer
for it to shake it all out.
Just using your fingers to shake out the waves.
Jamie, I can't wait for you to show this look to Drew.
I think this is a bit of a showstopper.
(audience clapping)
Jamie is here to show us her final hair transformation.
I'm sorry, I'm mesmerized.
Jamie, Welcome.
(audience cheering)
Wait.
(giggling)
How are you?
Take you out, Jamie.
You did it, you bombshell.
(laughing)
I got it.
Love it.
Jamie, you look so gorgeous.
Thank you.
I mean, this is very different hair
than where you started.
Yup.
Jamie, give us a swish.
Let's see you have moved, that's it.
I can't believe that my fine thin hair
could get so much volume.
But after your lesson, Chris,
it goes back and forth anywhere.
But the biggest thing I think was realizing
I could style my hair dry.
Just put a little products in there and do it
and it looks great.
And Jamie, we did it really fast, didn't we?
We literally turned that around in a few simple steps.
Yeah, so simple.
And Jamie, you are a knockout, a knockout.
Seriously.
Thank you.
All right, thank you, Jamie.
We're going to take a look
at Chris's next hair transformation.
Here's Maria, take a look.
Hello everyone, my name is Maria.
I'm 18 year old college student.
For the past 15 years, my hair has been the same.
Honestly, I'm getting bored of it.
I recently just turned 18
and I really needed to feel my most confident self.
I am the biggest fan of Ariana Grande.
And I think everybody knows
her signature ponytail that she does.
I think perfecting this Ariana ponytail
will really give me the boost of confidence that I need.
Drew, Chris, can you help me?
Maria!
Hi, Chris, oh my gosh.
I'm so excited.
I can't wait to show you how to get this
Ariana Grande's play ponytail.
Take the hair spray.
I'm going effectively just going to spray it
throughout the root section of the hair
using the cool favorite hair spray.
I am an ambassador, this is my favorite stuff.
So it's all about the cheekbone.
To get the perfect ponytail placement,
you want to follow this cheekbone.
Wow, I can already see its difference.
Okay, so get your elastic loops, a bit like this guys.
I put the hook in underneath the ponytail
and then wrap it around by tying again
with a second elastic.
We're going to tie it an inch above the ponytail
that we just did.
We have this magic powder.
So this is the Color Wow Touch Up Powder.
What I do is I go in
and just fill the half right now.
Perfect.
All right, so what we're going to do next
is you take a small strand of hair like this,
just enough and we're going to wrap it around the ponytail
in Ariana Grande's style.
Wow, Maria, that ponytail looks amazing.
I cannot wait for you to show Drew.
This is a showstopper.
(audience clapping)
And Maria is here now to show us how she looks, Maria.
Hi, oh my gosh I am so excited to be here.
Chris has changed my life.
He's changed the game for my hair.
I mean look at it.
I feel beautiful.
I feel so confident and amazing.
I love that.
Chris, it looks so good.
She looks insane.
She looks so good.
Yeah, it was so simple and easy.
And I didn't realize that a beautiful ponytail
so professional could take such less time
and you guys could do it too
in the comfort of your own home.
I mean, it's so easy and simple.
I just think you look gorgeous, Maria.
Thank you so much.
And Chris, you use some of the products
from Color Wow with Jamie and Maria
and you're the global creative director for that brand.
And guess what, VFFS.
You are all going home with a detox kit from Color Wow.
And that includes some amazing goodies for your hair.
(uplifting music)